DAZHI PENG: Hmm, hi, guys, they are seeing a lot of they can use in having the street going on this week.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, some are exciting, some are depressing. The exciting news is that opening I release it's latest multi-model gb 4 model
Jeffrey Feng: while less capable than humans in many real world scenarios exhibits human level performance on various professional academic benchmarks. For example, it passes simulated bar exam with a score around the top. 10% of test takers in contrast Gp: 3.5 score is around about 10%.
Yooni Choi: This was so exciting. Can't imagine what youpt for can do, since chat youpt is so powerful already. I haven't been using chat to it extensively for my everyday work.
DAZHI PENG: Gvd. 4 is so far according to open AI to be divorced, it's being the most reason probably available t in the case of all in Ps. And Ap. We're just pass questions. or by putting in 2,022 to 132.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, I think what's more exciting that can even accept visual inputs.
Jeffrey Feng: There was an example opening a website that the user asked, what's funny about this image, describe it panel by panel
Jeffrey Feng: and Gbd. 4 successfully identified all the interesting features of that image
Yooni Choi: given these features. I think it's definitely worthwhile for us to do a deep dive into its capabilities. Toddler, would you like to take on this task?
DAZHI PENG: Well, i'm pretty busy this week, so I don't think I could.
Jeffrey Feng: That's fine. I'll take it at the same time the bad news in the tech industry, if that matter started
Jeffrey Feng: another round of layout since last November. I think matter plan to lay off around 10,000 people.
Jeffrey Feng: or, roughly, 13% of its workforce.
Yooni Choi: That's a lot of people I remembered. Meta already laid off 10,000 employees last year. The layoffs will affect me as recruiting team this week, with a restructuring of his tech and business groups to come in May, April and May, Mr. Zuckerberg said in a memo posted on the Company's website.
DAZHI PENG: I also reduce Leo. You involve all methods, middle layer, management. So I earn it's going. February, the chief executive that it's been no on the company to be over with the layer of middle management or managers managing managers.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, this is an interesting question for us to investigate as well
Jeffrey Feng: whether too much middle management people are actually helping or hurting the company.
Yooni Choi: It makes sense, because Meta has kept changing from Meta to AI, or vice versa, there is definitely something wrong with their leadership structure.
DAZHI PENG: Then you will need for next week. Would you like to do some investigation on that?
Yooni Choi: No, I think we don't need to do so. I think it's just too much work.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, let's just not do it, anyway. This was an interesting discussion. Have a good week, Guys.